here's the science critic and i'm going
to put him on for a second so that you
can hear what he has to say and he's
going to say that another existing thing
that we have out there he says that
virtual particles exist he believes that
there are such things as virtual
particles gravity doesn't exist either
exactly because it's
a concept this is getting weird yeah you
can say that the ropes exist that cause
gravity but not the gravity or density
density
it just seems weird that all these
concepts got rid of all the concepts
that's also why you harp so much on not
using the word density mass and all
these things because they don't really
exist those are those are those concepts
in the sense that there's no there's no
shape there there's no thing that's
bumping into another thing there's
placeholders
they're placeholders that people don't
realize are price hold they put them in
and say oh the force did that what do
you mean the forces you mean the horse
the horse could have done and not the
force where's the oto when you need it
okay so this is the the um
this is our science critic
and he's going to say that virtual
particles exist and so the question to
you for you to think in the next few
minutes is do virtual particles exist if
you know what they are otherwise we're
going to enlighten you on what they are
so here we go give me a second so i put
this follow on
the questions and issues to be addressed
in this rebuttal include
are there such things as virtual
particles
virtual particles exist
now it sounds like what he's talking
about here are virtual particles and
virtual particles certainly explains
certain things like the casimir effect
just because you cannot imagine virtual
particles doesn't mean that they do not
exist now maybe that virtual particles
don't actually exist and there is some
other explanation for the casimir effect
but you need to actually come up with
another explanation for the kesmir
effect saying i can't imagine virtual
particles doesn't cut it
okay
so the question a million dollar
question today is do virtual particles
exist
and for those of you who don't know what
a virtual particle is let's find the
definition okay so here we have the
definition we find out there virtual
particle exhibits some of the
characteristics of an ordinary particle
okay while having its existence
limited by the uncertainty principle
it's existence limited they're limiting
the existence of god can you believe
this okay any object that exists for a
limited time that's what a virtual
particle is at limited time okay and
then virtual particles exist only
temporarily you know sounds quite ad hoc
to me if you if you ask me right the
lifetime of real particles is typically
vastly longer than the lifetime of the
virtual particles no kidding if it's got
a limited existence yeah and then they
finish saying the concept of virtual
particles
was a particle a thing an object or is
it a concept what do you mean a concept
of virtual particles it's the thing when
they need it to be yeah so so what do
they use virtual particles for
just one example i'll give you an
example i'll give you a couple examples
first let me give you the example of the
dark matter and the reason i need to put
that in there is that again is there
such a thing as dark matter is there a
physical object called dark matter out
there i ain't seen no dark matter in my
background it's not so much that first
they can't see it or touch it so that
would uh under the mathematical
definition c touch that would be
excluded anyways but they how do they
come up with dark matter why is it that
all mathematicians believe in dark
matter why all the astronomers pointing
their telescopes out there trying to
find it looking for an invisible thing
where did they get this idea well the
idea came because it was an equation
and they needed to figure out why the
stars on the outside on the outskirts of
the galaxy were traveling faster than
those around the galaxy faster than
those on the inside and so they said the
only thing they could come up with the
only explanation was mass
they said well we only have one solution
that's mass what else could it be and so
they put started putting mass they said
well
we're putting it by finger you know
we're putting it by hand in there we're
putting all this mass sprinkling it on
the outside of the galaxy just to make
the equation come out right
and they call that ad hoc putting of
kilograms out there they call that dark
matter so it was put in by hand and the
same thing comes with the virtual
particle they have an equation and
suddenly they accelerate a particle
along the beam line over there at cern
or slack or fermilab it doesn't do what
they calculated well they said you know
there's something else going on i need
some more charge i need some more mass i
need some more energy i need more
something in there to fill in the blank
because otherwise the equation doesn't
come out right
and so they said why don't we borrow
some energy some charge some mass and
whatever from this thing and put it in
the equation they say hey now the
equation works no kidding and they say
yeah but then suddenly the equation it's
like it suddenly goes away it goes it's
only a fleeting moment where they can
measure that and then it goes away and
so they said well
we got a solution we'll call it a
virtual particle it comes in when we
need it ad hoc
and then when we don't need it goes back
to i don't know to never never land i
sound like bad mathematicians like they
got the calculation wrong and then
they're like oh well
whatever we got wrong this is if
anything you could say it reversed you
could say they're good mathematicians
lousy physicists because they haven't
explained
how this really works and that explains
why mr
feynman says no one understands any
other but it seems like their
calculations are off too well their
calculations are off but they fix them
immediately they just put a you know a
variable in there by hand and they say
well there it is that's a solution we
put more charge more energy and in the
case of dark matter they put more mass
and it fixed the problem and now they
tell the astronomers go look for it
i love that what move the curtain god
now go look for them yeah the angels
yeah
point your telescopes
okay so here here's uh
here's my analysis okay a virtual
particle just a quick rundown virtual
particle is not a particle that's that's
the issue in qm a particle is not a
particle okay people think of particles
some kind of chord possible you know a
grain of dust uh grain of sand uh
you think of a little tiny
speck of dust of some kind that's what
you're thinking of that's what the
layman thinks every time he hears the
word particle that's not what a particle
is in quantum mechanics let alone a
virtual particle okay so what is a
particle well uh there's three kinds you
could say and they're all related to
sizes what is the macro particle the one
we all understand by the word particle
which is a speck of dust you know grain
of sand any of those right that's a
particle something you can see touch you
know macro we'll call it a macro
particle because you can see or touch it
you can relate to it then you have the
point particle here we go and and this
is a little tricky okay it has no size
it's a concept because it has no size
it's there's no volume no shape no
nothing there and they call that a
a particle a point particle right that's
a point particle and it could be a gluon
they call it a point particle it could
be an electron they call it a point
particle they've never seen one they
never photographed one they never
interviewed one so they don't know what
it looks like they have no idea and they
don't care what it looks like they just
give it values they say so much charge
so much mass they give it all all these
mathematical values these properties but
they don't tell you what it looks like
and they say we don't know what it looks
like we've never seen one paired we're
done and they call it a point particle
okay and part of that has to do with the
fact that the point particle they say
it's an elementary particle like you see
there at the bottom meaning it's not
made of anything smaller
it's like the ultimate particle it's not
made of anything itself at least for now
until they smash it and for that they
would need a collider as big as the
solar system you know so good luck with
that one and then you have the virtual
particle which is an ad hoc particle
which ain't a particle to begin with
particle is not a particle but here we
have a virtual non-particle
okay
and it appears at the whim of the
mathematician to make the equation come
out right so you have all these
different kinds of particles you should
be aware that when they're using the
word particle in quantum mechanics
they're not talking about that first one
the macro particle a real thing they're
talking about maybe a vibration local
vibration of a field maybe they're
talking about uh wave particle duality
uh the corkscrew you know uh that mr
roger penrose put in his book ridiculous
thing where he shows this corkscrew
that's supposed to represent both
notions the wave and the particle i mean
it's pretty close yeah of course that's
about it again good as it gets anyways
the point is um
you know this fellow believes in in
little ghosts in in uh spirits he thinks
that there are such things as virtual
particles because with it they can
explain the casimir effect well we don't
need the virtual particle before that we
always had spirits for that you know
angel is a god we already had all those
things but now you're just being
facetious no no i'm not being realistic
uh traditional religion probably had a
better answer than the virtual particle
which is a non-part non-entity to begin
with i mean if you bring an angel you
know i can imagine an angel he's got
wings you know a little plate on his
head i can say well he did this well
yeah okay gonna understand it was a ring
hopefully some people have played
something
i don't know uh but angels we can all
imagine but we cannot imagine a virtual
particle uh because it has no size no
shape it's just a value that they put in
an equation whenever they need it and it
flies away whenever they don't need it
so what is that it's it's just ad hoc
it's nonsense okay so yeah if i were to
choose i'll still stay with stick to
traditional religion and say that angels
explain it better than virtual particles
you